so how would you choose a topic for your
project this is going to start with
those of you
that are just planning to right you are
just thinking about
developing a project idea and maybe
you're thinking
how do i do something like a publication
that i read
or maybe you're thinking how do i do
something in
an area where i'm naturally interested
in but i really don't have the data
to start doing that kind of an
experiment
so that's the first point that i think
we should start from
is the topic that you already know and
care about so if you're currently doing
uh your phd you've selected a topic
you're maybe thinking of a particular
experiment
and you want to understand how to make
it more
impactful how does omics data factor
into this
if you're already conducting experiments
and you've collected data
you might be thinking how do i find
additional data
that i don't have the capability to
generate myself
but i really want to use it to make my
project more impactful
or i want to develop a new hypothesis
but i don't have the means to generate
the data
so that would be the first step is
really having
a topic that you know or you care about
and to ask yourself is that a topic that
i know and care about
is can you prepare a few slides to
explain
the topic background and can you see
yourself spending a few months
researching the topic so really
for those of you that are planning some
kind of bioinformatics analysis
even though it's just data analysis it
still takes time
so you have to be prepared to dedicate
at least several months
just to the analysis the second part
is what will be interesting to your
audience so i'm assuming
that the majority of you here are
already in
some kind of research and so if you
think about
your audience what is that audience that
audience could be
your peers your mentors other faculty
they could be the broader research
community and
this is not a trivial question for any
of those audiences
within a niche there's already a niche
within
every domain there are specific topics
that are
more interesting they're more
on top of everybody's mind and so
that's the second component here the
third
component is that you have to have the
data
and you have to have some kind of a
body of research that is available about
that topic right so if you are planning
to conduct this research
and there's no data you're back at the
same place right so it's got to be
something
that comes from availability of data
now in between at the intersection of
these three
is the project that you want to focus on
and i want to talk about this a little
bit more
in detail because that's where typically
most of the participants that we have in
our programs
fail they fail to quickly identify
a relevant topic that is interesting to
a broad community
and find data that can help them
make some kind of an interesting project
out of that question
so i think that defining that question
making it specific
and making it actually possible to
execute
is a big challenge that needs to be
overcome
now when people publish they typically
publish from primary data that they have
collected
and that is the raw data the first
hand observation that they have
themselves collected
in many cases you are not going to be
the person that generates that primary
data because
so much data is already available but
that doesn't mean
that you cannot start your project from
there
and so what we will do in the context of
the first part of our program
is we're going to kind of explore all of
these
sources of data to generate a hypothesis
or develop a problem or a question
and then find the solution or the answer
and i think that that has to do with an
overview
of literature but also the available
data sets
and it has to do with a good founding
a good established understanding of
methodology how
have others extracted insights from data
sets that they described
and so the typical process that we
recommend
is to start from where you are and try
to
define what is the specific
data set what is the problem statement
that you have
and then trying to work through on how
to make that
into a much more specific question
because that really
can help you then narrow down the number
of options that you have to do
your analysis and it will
streamline or simplify the
interpretation
at the end and so the first part is to
review
available sources and to categorize
them by some kind of type for example
you can think of
different types of research articles
that present
the current topics or that focus on one
specific thing
you can focus on a number of different
categories but you have to build out
that overview or that kind of a
landscape of where you are
compared to what's already out there
and then it will be more clear where are
the specific gaps
unanswered questions maybe controversy
right so some people don't agree with
each other and maybe a debate
and those are typically the most
interesting things
to address so that gap those unanswered
questions and those debates around
different topics is the place to focus
to define your question or hypothesis so
here what we want to do is we want to
kind of review what's out there make it
more specific
where do we want to focus and that
typically
will be in the place of gaps and
unanswered questions
now a good place to start is from
existing projects right so a part of
review
and by the way this doesn't have to be
just in your domain
is to see how have other people
tried to answer questions with data
and so what we've done is over the past
several years we've gone through
publications that focus on specific
types of problems and specific types of
data
and have extracted insights from that
data by processing
exploring and analyzing those data sets
so we've collected
a number of projects that you can
start with as a springboard into the
process
because they clearly take out the
methods
break down those methods into tutorials
that you can follow
explain the data set and how the data
set was collected
and why that data set is an impactful
way to study that particular topic
and once you've gone through a few
examples it becomes
almost easy for you to start thinking
about the data
in terms of a hypothesis that could be
answered
with a given set of tools and so when it
comes to
your project you are really going to be
able to take those examples
and leverage the same types of methods
to apply to a data set of your own
so this is how the program that we
envision
is going to work we're going to first
follow through
and learn about some of the basic data
types and how they are processed and
analyzed
then we will introduce case studies and
those case studies will provide you with
a good
overview of the topics where the data
came from
how it was analyzed and what are the
results
at the end you should develop a
framework
of how to apply such thinking to any new
data set or a problem
that you identify and so then we will go
to
focus on your independent project
where you will frame the problem and
framing the problem means
writing out the specific question and
how you plan to address it
then we'll go through finding the data
sets and that data
will be of different types and different
formats that we will
review process the data for analysis
with the right tools and today i'll show
you a few examples
perform in-depth analysis trying to
develop a statistical model that can
either prove or disprove your hypothesis
and then we'll also work with you on
communicating the results of the
analysis which is a very fulfilling
process because
it helps you get feedback early on from
a community of like-minded people
that will point out all of the details
that you need to address
for your final project so let's take an
example
and think about how to frame the problem
what does that actually mean so there
are several types of problems out there
for example you can take a clinical
problem
right so we all live in the era of
personalized medicine
and we can think of clinical challenges
in the context of personalized medicine
for example
patient stratification how do different
patients
respond to different pathogens how do
different patients respond to different
treatments
are there specific groups of patients
that we should be aware of
disease classification and diagnostics
how can we differentiate
one disease from another maybe one
disease staged from another disease
stage
maybe it is the predictive component how
can we identify
potential responders to therapies that
will respond better
to a therapy based on our mix data for
example
and also we can look at mechanism of
disease and disease progression
and that is more of a research question
and nevertheless
it plays a major role in how all of
these other questions could be addressed
another category of problems are related
to intervention
and so for the pharmaceutical and the
biotechnology companies what is
important for them
is to know biomarkers how can we
understand
specifically what is the molecular
process
that can help guide our decision making
that can help define
a diagnostic test we can think of
detection of toxicity right when there
are interventions
how do we know that those interventions
can have side effects and those side
effects could mean
toxicity at the maybe in vitro stage
as well as an analysis of molecular
mechanisms
of a drug action or target discovery
right so how can we use the information
that we have about a particular
interaction between an intervention and
the host
at the molecular level and understand
what are the targets
that we can focus on and how to
eliminate the targets that are
potentially
unreachable or unrealistic and also
a big domain in everywhere in
including infectious diseases and
non-infectious diseases
is drug repurposing and repositioning
right so how can we take existing
compounds
and apply them to a different type of a
challenge
or how can we take the same drug and
combine it with another one
or maybe modify its mode of use so that
it is positioned
in a different way so after we framed
the problem we need to find the data so
let's take a look
at a few data sources where you can
potentially identify
a data set for your research okay
so i'm going to go here to ncbi
and please follow with me to ncbi
this is the link
and please let me know once you've
reached ncbi by putting yes
into the chat box
and as we're doing that i want to say
that
the majority of the people that have
answered the first question
said number one so they're already
working
on a data of their own they've collected
their data they're
doing some analysis themselves and nine
people
said two so nine people said that
they're still planning or thinking about
a project
okay so please let me know once you've
reached ncbi by putting
yes in the chat box thank you mohammed
encourage
all right thank you okay it looks like a
lot of you
have okay so
another question for those of you that
already reached ncbi
on a scale from one to five one being
no experience and five being expert
how many of you have experience or what
is your level of experience
working with ncbi so one to five
five you're an expert one
you don't really know this is new to you
all right so i see that hosea
wrote number five so i'm gonna pass on
the microphone to jose he's going to
guide us
on a brief explanation of how to use
ncbi
and that that's a joke so for those of
you that are
very familiar with ncbi
that is a great thing what i think we
want to do today
is just look through some examples of
data sets that we can quickly find and
i'll show you how you can use them
even if they're very large even if
they're something that you
probably don't want to download to your
computer and
load up your laptop with this data set
so
here we have a search box on top
that searches for all databases okay so
think of any concept that you're
interested in
or any topic that you're interested in
and let's just see
what's out there so i'm going to take
the first five
examples that you post in the chat so
put down something
more or less specific okay so not just
the name of the organism
or a disease propose something a little
bit more
detailed a little bit more specific so
what type of a data set what type of a
problem statement what type of a
question do you have
that we can try to find data for
okay i'll take the first five
suggestions from the chat box
okay any suggestion does anyone have any
project in mind that they
don't mind sharing with the rest of the
group
okay so whole genome sequence again
whole genome sequence
is going to be a little bit difficult to
define because
that could mean anything right whole
genome sequence of what
what pathogen what okay great
so ahmad you can try again um
let's go to the next one gulshan tairoba
nyc tuberculosis
um so i don't know if that's referring
to new york city
or uh did you want to say mycobacterium
tuberculosis but again that's broad
right that's very broad that's just
a pathogen okay let's go to the next one
all mataio
is saying drug target for parkinson's
disease okay
let's try that okay so drug target
parkinson disease that would be number
one
okay a bukhari is saying micro satellite
sequencing data
again something i think a little bit
broad let's be more specific apply to
what what kind of a disease
or or something like that okay
a beer is saying rna microarray data for
the
lmk gene okay so
i have a little bit of a problem with
that because if you're using
microarray you probably don't want to
just choose one gene
right instead choose a pathology or
choose
a specific situation where this type of
data will be interested let's go on
hosea is saying comparative genomics of
covet 19 strains okay
perfect so covet 19 strings we don't
even have to
search anywhere we can look over here
source code 2 data so we'll take a look
at that example
and see what kind of data is out there
human microbiome and soil transmitted
hellmann's okay joelna aquari is
asking a very interesting question so
that's gonna be number three
let's see what we can find for for that
and this is personally
i do not know anything about this topic
and that's what's
exciting about my job i did to learn
about all of these interesting things
uh from you okay uh james
so we have one two three four so this is
the fourth okay so we have here
alka tanuria disease
james i would recommend being also a
little bit more specific
just the disease itself is probably too
broad so think of a
more specific question let's go to the
next one mohamed sagir
saying single nucleotide polymorphisms
of ace ii
i think it's interesting so let's take a
look but
i would mention that it's probably also
very broad right so let me
first of all fix this h2
okay so the last one let's see who's
going to be the lucky person
plasmodium falciparum that data okay so
that's interesting but let's
again be more specific let's go to the
next one
mance mansonella species in
africa okay let's let's try
[Music]
okay so let's go to the first one
so the first project that you proposed
was
drug target in parkinson's disease
and so let's take a look briefly at what
types of data are available
and how much so there's a lot of books
and publications and different kinds of
references
in literature which obviously we would
expect
but here we have some information about
genes now
who knows what does geo stand for
does anyone know what geo stands for
gene expression omnibus okay thank you a
beer
that's in fact correct so we have here a
number of
gene expression data so we don't have a
lot
but we have a few data sets now let's
think whether
gene expression is a good way to study
drug targets for parkinson's disease
i think it is a good uh data type
because
when we look at how a drug
affects a particular tissue or a cell
line or a whole
whole organism what we really want to
know is whether
there is a protein a receptor on the
surface cell or some kind of a surface
protein that could be accessible for a
drug
is playing a major role in this disease
and therefore if we interact with it we
can potentially make a difference we can
change something
so i think that's a perfect example so
let's take a look at what kind of data
do we have here
as a drug target for parkinson's disease
so here we have
gene expression of a53t and
corrected ipsc driven to d8
neurons and exposed to paraquat and
monet
okay so a lot of gibberish that i
personally don't understand so i would
love to learn more
and i can click here for more and read
about the organism experiment type
summary
the overall design and potentially even
a publication that i could read
but let's go and see what do we actually
have what type of data do we have here
so here
it says we have 12 samples and the
important part to think
right is how can this data inform me
about making a reasonable question that
i could be answering with such data
so what i see here is that we have four
different groups
in each group we'll have three
replicates and those replicas are
corresponding with some condition
so if i was to start looking through the
data sets
i would need to structure the data in
such a way that i can
ask questions by for example making a
contrast
between one group and another group
or maybe through classification where i
can identify
different features that are specific
that are unique
to a particular condition so it looks
like
if i'm interested in finding a data set
to start
asking questions about some particular
drug or a pathway for a new drug target
this would be a good data set to start
okay so
for the first one we found data in about
a couple of minutes
let's go to the second one so here
it's obvious that we're going to find a
lot of data every lab in the world that
was shut down for any other purpose
found a way to repurpose their research
to study source code 2 and so much data
has been generated
just in the context of this pandemic
that it surpassed every other pandemic
before this including ebola virus cells
1
zika etc in fact we saw a four-fold
increase in the number of genomes
generated
every month for sars cove ii compared to
all of the other types of previous
outbreaks combined so i think there's a
huge number of data sets
you can see that there are over 185
000 sra runs so who knows what
sra stands for
i'm assuming uh some of you that put
number five
for the previous question are very
familiar with these abbreviations
so please let us know what does sra
stand for
[Music]
all right excellent thank you a beer
sequence read archive
exactly so here we will find compressed
fastq
files that contain sequencing read data
and from those sequencing reads we can
study
gene expression genome variation we can
identify
groups of different viruses inside
patients etc etc so over 185 000 of
these
53 000 nucleotide records so
genomes or genes or proteins clinical
trial data publications and references
so
really a whole collection that you can
scroll through so i'm not going to go in
detail
anything you want to ask about
coronavirus most likely somebody
generated some data that you can find
and study that let's take a look at this
one very specific problem
here human microbiome and soil
transmitted helmets
so if we look here we're struggling to
find
any raw data we have some publications
we have some books
but we don't have any data sets so let's
try to find nevertheless
what is going on with these soil
transmitted helmets so the first thing
that i already know that there's a lot
of data on the human microbiome
so i can pause with that real quick and
look for soil transmitted helmets and
see if i can find anything for that
and it looks like i can now because
i'm interested in the microbiome i know
it's not going to be in the gene
expression omnibus data because that's
going to be gene expression
and i'm looking for microbiome a
different type of data
so probably i want to go into the bio
project and see
what can i find here and here
i do have one bioproject that deals with
the metagenome
okay so what do we have here the impact
of enthalmentic treatment on human gut
microbiota in western kenya
cross-sectional and pre-post deworming
comparisons
i think this is exactly the type of data
that you're looking for right i forgot
who asked this question but
do you think this is a data set that
could help you study this
topic okay whoever
okay great so there's your project so
here you have
211 samples already for you
right you don't have to generate a
single sample because first of all
you probably want to understand whether
this data set contains some
interesting insights into what you are
trying to
identify so there we go a complicated
challenging research question and we
found data for it in just a few minutes
all right so another question was single
nucleotide polymorphisms of
ace ii so whoever asked that please add
a little bit more detail in the chat box
so we can kind of take this further
but it's an interesting question we all
have heard
that h2 is the primary target for the
covet 19 source code ii virus
we know that h2 is expressed in the
lungs and other tissues
and maybe the question is whether there
is a genetic component
to people that have acute reaction to
source growth 2 or a milder reaction to
source of two
maybe some other types of information
like ethnic background
or other important information could be
a factor here right
so obviously we're going to find a lot
of data here
but i think we need to structure the
question better to find
good responses so ace2
how do we find single nucleotide
polymorphisms
single nucleotide polymorphisms are
found in
genome sequencing data and so instead of
looking for
single nucleotide polymorphisms in h2
i would just probably want to find some
data set
that i could query or i could search
through to find
polymorphisms typically found in maybe a
healthy population
or maybe between different tissues or
potentially between different species
as i can see here right so if i
focus on the homo sapiens h2
let's search for that
okay here i have
again bio project
so let's take a look at bio project
okay here we can clear all because we're
in the filter for metagenome
and because this is going to be genomic
data
unfortunately i don't see genomic data i
see epigenomics
other which i don't know what that would
be transcriptome so
it looks like maybe we need to
search through um so so
whoever proposed this do you have a more
specific question here
okay i'll wait for you to come back
because i think that here
in the context of ace 2 it would be
interesting to
see what the specific question would be
that does it have polymorphisms
probably yes do you want to just compare
different
people or do you want to find a
particular
position or how do you want to use that
information right
that's i think where you need to think a
little bit more and propose
how to make it more specific okay so now
let's look
we have manzanella species in africa
so again unfortunately this is kind of
broad
right so i think if we just look for
manzanella
and then we see what kind of information
do we have about mansonella it looks
like we have some
geodata some gene expression data some
bio
projects so let's take a look if any of
these are
in africa
okay let's see where was this collected
if we can find out
looks like a very recent data set
a genomics okay
do we know where it came from
let's see
[Music]
um
okay unfortunately it does not tell us
where was collected from and it's a very
recent sample
but i can imagine that you would be able
to find
data depending on what is your research
question what are you trying to find
right
so the point of this is that i think for
the majority of the projects that you
propose so three out of five
we found data very quickly for the other
ones
it took us a little bit of time
primarily because
you need to be very specific when you're
asking the question
just like those three good ones asked
right it's the microbiome
for this particular pathogen and we
found that data right
once you can define your question with
the type of data
the type of a organism the type of a
specific question that you have
that helps you very quickly answer the
question
about whether that data exists and
remember let's go back
really quickly to that slide when you
choose your problem
you need to care about it right so some
of you have proposed your questions
presumably you care about them number
two
it has to be interesting to your
audience so that's up to you to decide
but three that's an important component
you have to have
a data set to start working with to be
able to work
on that project so that's an important
component here that we always go through
so we've thought about how to frame the
problem again
several examples of how to frame the
problem
and how to explore whether that problem
could be answered with data
now let's talk about processing the data
so many of the data sets that we have
looked at
will require processing of raw data for
example when we looked at the sequence
read archive
those contain individual read reads
from sequencers those need to be
pre-processed
then they have to be mapped they
potentially if it's gene expression you
have to go to
quantification maybe differential gene
expression
or you're free to start asking the
question
what is the signal to noise ratio what
kind of signal am i looking for
that can help answer my question so in
the context of this program
we'll take a look at several types of
data sets
including viral sequencing or
metagenomic sequencing we'll take a look
at
genomic data how the whole genome
sequencing whole exome sequencing
or genomic genome assembly for pathogens
works
and we'll also look at transcriptomic
data so we'll learn how to process that
data
to go from individual reads to a table
of expression
a big step that many people overlook
is the exploratory data analysis step
so as we saw we found
a number of data sets and those data
sets
have been prepared by different labs
different
hands did the sequencing they did it in
different conditions
we need to know that the data is solid
that we can use it that it doesn't have
any artifacts that are going to lead us
astray
so let's see whether we can find some
data set
and quickly explore it okay
so here we have expression profiling by
array i'm just going to use this example
to show you
what kind of data exploration could be
meaningful
in this case here we have
six or sorry three replicates per
condition
so let's take a look how can we explore
this data
so here we have the table so let's
download this table really quickly
it's going to be a big table but we'll
take a look at what's inside
okay so i'm going to take this table and
let me
unzip it
okay i'm just going to open it up
in excel and let me read here a little
bit more
what does this data describe so
parkinson's disease pd is characterized
by extensive loss of
a9 dopam dopamine
dopaminergic da neurons
in the substantia and negra pars
compacta snpc
okay okay
a strong association has been reported
between pd and exposure to mitochondrial
toxins such as the environmental
pesticides paraquat miniv and retinol
here using a robust patient-derived stem
cell model of pd that allows comparison
of cyanuclean
mutant cells and isogenic mutation
corrective controls we identify
mitochondrial toxin-induced
perturbations
specific to a53t syn mutant
a9da neurons we report a novel molecular
pathway whereby
basal as well as toxin induced oxidative
and nitrosate of stress inhibits the
mef2cpgc transcription network in a53t
hns compared to corrective controls
contributing
to mitochondrial dysfunction and
apoptotic cell death
our data provide mechanistic insight
into gene environmental interactions
in the pathogenesis of pde furthermore
using small molecule high throughput
screening we identified the mef2cpgc1
pathway
as a new drug target for therapeutic
benefit in pd
so here we know that this is a mutant
right this is a53t mutants so
a53t this is the mutant
uh and here's another a53t
a53t right so what is p q
and so i think that these were
um paraquat maybe
mb paraquat and moneb and rotten
so maybe these are the pesticides so
maybe this is the mutant with pesticides
this is the control with pesticides this
the mutant without pesticides
this is the control without the
pesticides so
my question would be as i want to
explore this data
could i use would i be able to see
clearly
differences between the control group
and the treated group or
between the mutant and the control so
let's try
and figure that out
so here's my data i'm going to just
change this to id
and actually i'm going to use
uh i'm going to use this because right
now i'm not interested
in specific genes here
i have the names
of probes it looks like
so what i okay okay so this is not
useful okay unfortunately
with this data set it is designed around
probes
and so i cannot just take the data set
as a
table of expression what i probably will
be able to do is get the raw data
and find that data inside okay but
theoretically
what i would want to do is i would want
to explore this data using something
like principal component analysis
to see whether the groups separate and
the important next step here
is to be able to structure this
analysis in depth right so here
we have an example of what i wanted to
show you unfortunately the data wasn't
ready for it which is actually
80 of the case that's what you're going
to find but once i structure the data
and i find the right
table i could perform something like
principal component analysis
that would help me design the specific
contrasts
that i could turn into biologically
interpretable analysis okay
so i'm going to pause here and ask you
if you have any questions about what we
did
and how you are thinking about
your own project so help does this
ability to find reference data sets on
ncbi
and public domain repositories does it
help
your project do you see yourself being
able to leverage these resources
to be able to ask such questions
okay so the other example that i briefly
wanted to show you
is this one okay so the second
problem that we will take a look at
today
is working with large numbers of data
sets so again
you can see here is there are 211
samples okay so to process these samples
you actually don't have to download the
data to your computer so in the context
of our program we're going to provide
you with
access to our server platform
that is a big data platform so please go
with me to server.tnashbio.info
and we'll take a look at the second data
set
okay so here what's important is
to understand how was this data prepared
okay deep so maybe you could share the
demo account details
okay so what's important here is to
understand
how this data was prepared and you can
see here
that this is amplicon data
using aluminum my seek and it is
metagenomic
it's pcr and it's paired and because it
is
metagenomic using my seek
i probably think that this is going to
be amplicon data
so what it's going to simplify for us
is that it's only going to provide us
with sequencing of the 16s
ribosomal rna gene and that will allow
us to study
data about microbiome composition
and species richness so if i want to
analyze all of these datasets again one
of my options
is to download all of them to my
computer and start running
a pipeline on my computer but i can see
how this can quickly get out of control
because there's just so many samples and
each one of them
is fairly large so instead of
doing that what i will do is i will
send the results to run selector or
over here go to file
and download the run info table
and what this will do
okay what this will do is they will
create a table
from which the server will itself pull
the data from
ncbi and i will be able to run
this analysis without requiring
any kind of computational power from my
own computer
so let me show you how to do that okay
here we have
the runs 211 runs
and here there's a download link which
typically i could use
using sra tools to download to my
computer but i'm going to skip that
okay so here we also have
the description okay they were taken
from different
dates it looks like
and
all of them okay so this table
let's go to the server could be analyzed
with either the data two pipeline
right here or kind two
so let's use this amplicon 16s
example to see what we can learn
from this data set so here we have a
demo
of what this pipeline would look like
and so i'll just briefly explain
once the data is loaded you go through
the data
workflow which clears up the sequencing
reads
and prepares a table of operational
taxonomic units
that is then cleaned up and
prepared for analysis using phyloseek
that will show us how the distribution
of species in different samples varies
based on in this case i think infection
so
as a result you will get a number of
outputs
that include visual outputs and table
outputs
that could be further used to study
these in detail
how do we actually upload the data
instead of the demo
now with the credentials that beeps have
provided you cannot do this but
once you join the program you'll get
your own personal account
here i have the ability to select silva
as my reference database
i will add the file that i just
downloaded
as an ncbi run table so i'll do add file
and here
i'll take this table that i uploaded
and here i actually don't have
a supplementary text file
but i'll just upload something else and
now i can
start this pipeline so without
downloading
any of the files just providing the
reference
links to ncbi and defining what groups
those samples would fall in
i can start this pipeline and create for
myself
a full metagenomic analysis
understanding species composition and
richness
between those different samples in the
microbiome
okay so briefly i think what we went
through today
is how to find data
which could include looking on ncbi like
we did today
it can include raw data on different
repositories like
sra bio projects and geo
and other dedicated databases
for example somebody mentioned
plasmodium falciparum
so there's a full database of data
specifically on plasmodium falciparum
plasmodb then
we talked about how to do exploratory
data analysis
and that can include running something
like principal component analysis or
looking at
summary statistics for my data
understanding whether
i can use that data and make reliable
inference from my analysis
then we talked about doing meaningful
analysis
translating my question into a model
into a test in a particular analysis
that i will want to run and finally
you will get to your result so
what is the result what should be
included
in the result of my analysis
so as we said in the beginning you start
with the project name
and selection of your topic you then
perform
specific tasks you downloaded the files
from somewhere
you analyze them in some way all of
those steps need to be recorded
so what's going to be important in the
context of this three-month program
is the ability to keep a journal where
you record
all of this information that later on
will be included in your poster
in your report or in your publication so
there you will
describe who generated the data and how
what are the sample names and how do you
find those samples
if somebody else wants to reproduce your
analysis what are the specific analyses
that you've run
how did you transform the data or
manipulate it before you ran an analysis
and so all of those tie in into
your results and discussion how does
your result
compare to what other people did
especially if you took some
other people's data and what
does your analysis contribute what new
information does your analysis
contribute
to what is already known about this
topic
so this is just a brief overview today
that we saw about
starting your project finding the data
and planning your analysis